who's your favorite fighter to watch
these days like of the young guys coming
up
oh man well that not young guys yet
there's still glo glover take sarah's
still out there so yeah okay sure
is the champ still right yeah he's
ranked like top
top five yeah
he's one he's one of my guys he's
training with me nice
he's uh he's a good dude man i really
like him and how old is he now he'd be
jan blehovich for the title does he
still have the title yeah he's guys
uh shanghai uh june right yeah he fights
yeah that's [ __ ] scary man but do i
love watching all these old guys
uh
kill it you know i like that the old
guys are doing pretty [ __ ] well these
days like andre arlovsky with all the
victories and glover to share as the
champ and
[ __ ] uh
who else is that like uh like uh
alexi olenick just had a victory he's
[ __ ] 44 years old wow awesome yeah it
was his 77th pro fight he's 44 years old
it's crazy and he [ __ ] like was in
deep trouble and he [ __ ] switched
around and and that was great wow i
don't miss a fight chuck i'm a [ __ ]
that's awesome i'm i'm gnarly do you
watch them all no
i i still love fights i still watch them
but i just don't i met kids and yeah
it's hard to start to get the time to
watch all of them it's got to feel good
that whenever you're at the
pay-per-views and you're at most of them
that like hearing the crowd roar when
they show you on the screen yeah it's
it's so cool yeah that's so cool to have
for sure that's fun
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and stuff i filmed
for this show is way too hot for jackass
like the general anesthesia bike ride
the vasectomy olympics and sky jacking
the footage is so intense we have full
grown men passing out at almost every
city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you